foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you what is cracking everyone
welcome to the gc4 the gorilla
Collective 2023 summer barbecue beach
house festival showcase we are bringing
the heat that is going to set the tone
for things to come during this wild week
of gaming events I am your host J dub
AKA Justin Woodward co-founder of the
mix the media Indie Exchange in terabang
entertainment advisor on the black game
developer fund and black voices in
gaming I'm with my lovely co-host The
Talented Jay Watts AJ what's up Justin I
am Jay Watts artistically known as
letter J and I am the founder and CEO of
core exist gaming we are starting off
this week of gaming showcases and events
which has come full circle with us
filming at the kind of funny studio in
San Francisco shout out to the KF team
some history about the GC
the gorilla Collective was created due
to the Fallout of 2020 and no in-person
E3 so we decided to come together with
Publishers Developers
game enthusiasts to organize and deploy
showcases guerrilla marketing style and
add some flavor and Style by giving
folks a creative jolt this summer we're
definitely giving people that flavor
that Joe this year is no different we
are sparking off the summer Sizzle by
dropping some exclusive game drops
reveals updates and developer commentary
for their titles it doesn't stop there
though after this show we will pass the
mic to our friends who will be making
some more reveals and drops at the
gorilla Collective publisher Spotlight
Show featuring awesome new game
announcements from Freedom Games pipe
train digital and Tiny build if you're
in La we got some more stuff happening
so it doesn't stop there in LA we're
going to be invading the scene with 40
new games at wisdom for a lot and we
have a live stream with our partners viz
and the completionist more info at me
media Indie exchange.com and we will
also follow things up next week with
black voices and gaming and games for
games which highlights black game
developers and women in the game
industry check us out on Twitter at
gorilla collect not gorilla collect and
at Indie exchange and everywhere else at
gorilla Collective and media Indie
exchange make sure to tune in into our
twitch subscribe to our YouTube channels
as well the developers and Publishers on
the stream have blessed us with the
steam keys from games in their catalog
when you see the following QR code grab
your phones take a flick your chance to
grab a great game
we've also teamed up with the Exquisite
Folks at valve to showcase our stream on
their platform in order to support the
devs
be sure to check out the event page on
Steam where you can wish list buy or
play the games that are featured in this
event
definitely do that it always helps and
we also have some amazing sponsors we
want to give a big shout out to all of
them for helping us to make this thing
happen Freedom hype train digital
PlayStation raw Fury tiny build assemble
entertainment akupara Astro herocraft
joystick Ventures neon Doctrine Raven
age Razer steam I was about to say
stream yes bird wired Productions and
experience Studios such a mouthful yes
and shout out to our broadcasting
partners for shooting this showcase and
the developers on the stream twitch IGN
Gamespot Steam and kind of funny for
hosting us big up for the developers
always showing love to the devs who are
participating and all that have
contributed their games and resources to
make this thing possible yes they are so
awesome
but enough of all that let's get started
with our first set of games this summer
with some undeniable bangers beginning
with a world premiere trailer
let's go let's go
foreign
[Music]
if dust piles up it will become a
mountain
continuing on is where true strength
lies a tale can be told in an evening
a legend takes decades to build
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
the big
is larger than life you will need to
start
a dynasty
[Music]
foreign
mold his surroundings
[Music]
destroy his wisdom
conquer distances
oh
symbols of his divinity
[Music]
we are forgotlings
thank you
[Music]
nobody's Beyond Redemption Chelsea
nobody no matter who they are what
they've done
the right path is always there
if we choose to walk it
[Music]
to deception I sacrificed my health my
body my life everything
[Music]
what do you want my employers have a job
for you you ever heard of the
underground fight championship
oh the game is still being played
Chelsea you just never realized it
because you're only a pawn
oh
[Applause]
you want me to keep a secret that's
gonna cost you
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not a pawn anymore now I'm one of
the players
[Music]
I don't know who you people are but I am
coming for you
[Music]
still afraid of the dark sis
from time to time I ask myself is it
possible to miss something you've never
known
let me rephrase
is it possible to be homesick for a
place you have never been
[Music]
I was born on Earth but I think I have
been homesick for Europa my whole life
foreign
[Music]
and the world will look very different
from how it does now
but the island should still be there
they plug this thing to last
[Music]
come to the island
come here
and think of me
thank you
foreign
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Hello darling and welcome to dwarf delve
a randomly generated roguelite set
within treacherous mines filled with
Darkness dangers and above all else loot
as a newly recruited dwarf in training
your essential duties will see you
scouring the deepest darkest Minds for
anything of value tin gold maybe even
Treasures of a less common nature
stepping into the boots of a new Dublin
can be tricky luckily each time you risk
your beard for Lou to make it out alive
you can spend your ill-gotten gains on
Plenty of new tools and equipment
upgrades
assuming you make it back alive you can
use on your resources to upgrade every
element of your gear or even construct
entirely new support items you can also
exchange loot for skill points
increasing how hard you can hit how far
you can throw and how much you can carry
between your adventures you'll be able
to relax in your quarters upgrade your
living quarters with a huge array of
wallpapers rugs carpets paintings even
new cushions
here you can refine oars into crafting
materials purchase new Furnishings for
your home and even do a spot of cooking
you might even find special edible
ingredients giving you special perks
when you cook them into fully prepared
meals in the future unlock the workbench
to unpack and build flat-packed newly
purchased item blueprints even following
the included construction guide
build a rail and Minecart Network to
move your loot around once you dig
deeper for rarer Treasures but remember
it's best not to get too greedy these
mines are ancient and unstable one wrong
boot could cost you your life dwarf
delve was developed with a love of
exploration and discovering shiny loot
in mind from sandbox titles such as
Minecraft and stardew Valley to Rogues
such as Diablo and Borderlands I wanted
to include as many Secrets as possible
within the environment from puzzle
dungeons to obscure items that would
make players come together to solve and
build a sense of community the
experience is constantly evolving and I
look forward to raising up our battle
mallets together very soon
foreign
[Music]
led to our greatest Triumph
and
our ultimate downfall
we opened the door to Worlds beyond our
comprehension but from that door an
unimaginable evil called the root
slipped through
and destroyed everything
a couple decades back we dealt the root
of heavy blow
bought ourselves some time
we rebuilt as best we could lift our
wounds and forged a path forward step by
step
but our time is running out everything
is prey to the root and as long as they
exist we will always be hunted
that's where you come in
we need you to journey to some dangerous
yet wondrous firms and stop the route
once and for all just
to survive you'll need to push every
skill you've got to its limit
but we don't just need you to survive we
need you to Prevail use whatever gear
you can find
modify your weapons with what you can
scrounge up in your travels
bring the backup you need
we're counting on your travel stop this
infestation before it extinguishes the
last flickering flame of humanity
if you fail well let's just say failure
isn't an option
our future is in your hands now
without you
everything we know and love will fall to
Ash
foreign
Ty came out of nowhere and is looking
super interesting it's great to have
games from all over the world showcase
at the event indeed once again we've
teamed up with the Exquisite Folks at
valve to showcase our stream on their
platforms in order to support the devs
it's all about the devs be sure to check
out the event the event page on Steam
where you can wish list buy or play the
games that are featured in this very
event up next if you like takes on 2D
Classics or fast-paced action our next
segment dives into some fun and
compelling takes on games in the Neo
retro genre Let's Roll
[Music]
foreign
my name is Jacob also known in the
community as hipshot and I'm the
creative director here at track show in
this video I will import explain how
Hammer 2 differs from our previous
titles the original have worked from
2013 and here also have more from 2018.
I won't dive into everything different
because it would be a video too long but
I will pick out a few major features as
you might know the first game is a
simple fixed hack and slasher and heroes
of hammer watch is a roguelite with
randomly generated levels allow with the
sequel we are going for a more
open-ended action adventure experience
the first big thing is of course player
classes the characters that you play as
throughout your journey they are very
simple in the first game and you only
have q active and a few passive skills
and here's a homework it was all
expanded with more variation different
damage type for added and where it fixed
all of this of course with hamwork 2 we
Crank that up with tons of active and
passive skills which themselves have
cool subskins and all classes now have a
range alternative if they had none in
the previous games so it's actually
possible to make an entirely range
Paladin in homework too no she no sword
but whatever class it takes in this
items and gear in the first game we
really didn't have any items in gear we
had a few permanent upgrades but that
that's kind of it in Heroes we added
collectible items with great variety not
might change the game experience quite a
bit for hammers 2 we have made a system
more similar to bigger action RPGs where
you collect items in your inventory that
you can equip sell or just throw away
you get the items from Fallen enemies
hit the secret solving quests or buying
them from some store or you can even
craft them gear and Equipment have
different randomized stats and features
some other items are made for crafting
purposes some items are made to be used
once some are made for quests and some
are just use them speaking of quests to
where we had very simple missions in
both previous games like finding those
planks or that prison button we now have
a fully fledged out system with dialogue
different choices and rewards quests can
be completely in various ways and can
become very Advanced most quests you get
from non-playable characters roaming
around in their beautiful world of
hammers too and while we're on the
subject of world and levels the first
game had a very linear design path where
Heroes had a generated level system that
changed every time you play in hammers 2
we have made a sort of a mix of that
with some design levels with randomized
features in them or levels generated
from some kind of prefab composition mix
and for the first time you will now have
a huge outside world to explore and take
in so those are some of the pictures in
how much 2. take care now and bye bye
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Summit
[Music]
foreign
my story
[Music]
we're hitting
here
tonight
[Music]
come on Crusaders it's cleanup time
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ton
I'm destruction worker
some people call me the Dynamite Man
you know it's pretty hard being a single
dad
you're raising a little pink Hedgehog
girl
you know I used to be an exterminator
it was a really bad job I would fall
down sewers fall down manholes
and we have to climb my way back up
and then my roommate would just tell me
you smell like
you know kids always come up to me and
they're like
and I gotta go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
here want to buy Anton Bliss
it's time to paint the town red in Anton
blast an explosive Adventure coming soon
to steam a Nintendo switch
[Music]
are you still here
so Justin I know you're making some
waves making that happen you make new
waves in the Neo retro games shout out
to gram of legend for dropping his
latest
super space Club is part of the black
voices in gaming
what was one of your favorite games in
the last segment one of my favorite
games which kind of came out of nowhere
was toxic Crusaders side-scrolling
brawler it looks super dope it's taking
me back to my childhood with all the
trauma movies also Anton Blast has this
fast-paced leveled up Wario type of vibe
super dope definitely make sure to check
out those games on the gorilla
Collective steam page wish list of games
play the demos it helps them out I can't
say that enough yo shout out to steam up
next we are raising the stakes and
creeping into your mind like Freddy
Creeps in the dreams with some new
trailers in the horror genre we've got
an update for the junji Edo inspired
world of Horrors and we're gonna mix
things up with some fast-paced shooters
that sounds mad spooky I can't wait to
get my pants scared off I'm here for it
[Music]
thank you
welcome to Sarah an immersive Survival
game where you're trapped in a world
engulfed by a green toxic substance
you're stranded without any memory of
how you got there and a device implanted
in your hand ticks down the seconds
until your life is over
in order to survive you need to inject
yourself with serum and that's where the
game's unique Brewing System comes into
play
by mixing and matching different types
of substances you can unlock dozens of
powers and hidden abilities that will
help you survive
to extract the liquid you'll need to
gather plants and hunt down mutated
animals that lurk in the shadows
you also find mysterious notes and
blueprints left behind by someone that
has been there before
use those to craft devices weapons and
deadly traps
uncover the truth about the dark
mysteries of this world and prepare for
their final encounter alone or in a
co-op mode
foreign
[Music]
life is in your hands
come on
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the deputy and many of the locals
believe this is the doing of the devil
hi there I'm Sid a Dev at metric Empire
in our game battle Shapers you're
playing as Ada who's reactivated to
Renegade robot overlords who have taken
over the city working with what little
information you and Ada have you'll be
gunning down hordes of enemy machines in
our blockbusting roguelite Ada is
equipped to work all different kinds of
cool guns and if that's not enough her
fist will certainly do the trick
once you've perfected wielding powerful
weapons and abilities it's time to steal
some game-changing Powers by defeating
these ruthless overlords
once you've beaten Overlord you'll be
able to equip and use their powers
unlocking sick new suits and matching
gauntlets
but let me warn you getting these cores
will not be easy the road ahead is full
of danger like corrupted towers and
enemies it's clear these overlords are
not playing around it's up to you to
save the city of New Elysium and bring
it back to the Utopia it once was
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
together
foreign
horse
[Music]
white man brought with him corruption
agreed
[Music]
vanity
ignorance
[Music]
he killed the Holy Ground and the great
spirit has abandoned this place the dead
can no longer leave
restless and enraged they wand in the
Earth
every flesh
the fake worse than death
undeserving even for a stupid white man
flickers within you a stranger
go now leave this place be the great
spirits take pity on you may your soul
find peace in the spirit world
[Music]
yo Sparky is destined to be streaming
and YouTube slash twitch famous I can
already see it blood West is a great
addition to the throwback FPS Gore Fest
from back in the day looking forward to
being creeped out by all of those titles
I mean world of horror we've had that in
a couple showcases it's been a game
changer in the genre we can't wait for
the updated version of that release
super super dope before we move on we
want to thank all of you all for tuning
in and checking out the games in this
showcase but after this there's gonna be
more
we have a Showcase with our friends at
Freedom Games tiny build and hype train
digital with the gorilla Collective
publisher spotlights
we do and also make sure you check out
our mix merch store to support us we've
got caps shirts pins the whole nine to
make you wet with amazing drip Madrid
coming up we're also gonna take you
through a tour of various up and coming
RPGs and titles that will have you
taking up epic side quests with style
grab your Maps potions the turnbuckle
and your favorite classmate and let's
hop in let's get it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
being a bishop Ain't Easy
it takes a toll in ways you can't
imagine
there you'll find out the same thing now
get back to work feel sales power
[Music]
I have no time for this
I could have timed that better
[Music]
I've gotta be faster
there are things that the living cannot
understand
[Music]
death is only the beginning of the final
voyage
it's just not
[Music]
has arrived
ready for another adventure
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to wrestle Quest my name is Zach
I'm the chief Power Bomb Enthusiast at
Mega cat Studios and I'm here to show
you some never before seen content so
without further Ado let's get down to it
so the area we're showing you today is
the jungle audio Wilds it is a jungle
themed board game and as you can see
we've got some pretty cool effects here
we know we've got the sunlight coming in
these leaves blowing in the wind and
this gorgeous River why do we add a
river well if you want to make them
quiver you gotta have a river right this
is the dungeon that's sort of towards
the beginning of the game after the
first initial act as you open up and get
to start exploring you know the rest of
the world map so we're going to show you
some of the features this dungeon has to
offer
we've got another enemy type here in the
middle there the Luchador piggy bank the
money Pig
bruder's gonna take care of them for us
now you'll notice how he shattered there
um not all enemies will need pinned only
enemies that are wrestling based are you
know sort of like tough guy characters
so here we have this kind of swinging
bug zapper here useful for the jungle No
Doubt
as you get even deeper into larger
you'll come to this area the bright
light caves as you can see there's these
Prismatic sprays of fire that are hot
enough to melt the shades right off your
face I just took one darn it that's all
right
I just snuck by that enemy every enemy
in the game has a certain uh movement
pattern that if you watch and wait you
can usually sneak by them a lot of times
that forces you into a decision of you
know do I want to fight this guy or that
guy over there because of the way their
patterns overlap so the bright light
caves have these colored rocks and these
light bulbs and you can find colored
sheets to place over the light bulbs so
replace a sheet changes the light of the
bulb which if it matches the Rocks makes
them disappears you can continue on your
way
and it gets more complicated as you get
multiple sheets that you can combine
from multiple colors multiple rocks
blocking your way but if you manage to
go through everything there's some
unique rewards you can find here here we
are what appears to be another statue
area
what could it be with these scaly
slithering oh my gosh it's Jake The
Snake that's right Jake the Snake
Roberts is here in Russell Quest we
can't do a rest request video without
talking about our main guy here right
macho man that's right there are
multiple Macho Man statues across this
gigantic world map and if you visit them
all you might just get the best prize
thank you for joining us on this tour of
junk lodgy from wrestle Quest it's just
one of the many many areas in the game's
massive World we're excited to get
Russell Quest into your hands later this
summer until then stay sweaty
[Music]
reality
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I can't wait to jump off the turnbuckle
in wrestle Quest
I can't either I've been waiting for
that one since it was announced I love
that they look like articulated WWE toys
they're so cute they look they look
super dope I love those toys back in the
day yes
I've also been waiting to share demon
School goodness as a big fan of the
original Persona or Persona how do you
say it it's looking super sick shout out
to necrosoft for sharing that game with
us but you know what Jay what you know
what time it is what time is it it is
key giveaway time get the key drop kids
grab your phone scan the QR code on your
camera
go to the website for your chance to get
a key from the developers and Publishers
in the Showcase they could be previous
titles it's a grab bag awesome games
that we're giving away
up next we have some really big world
premieres and exclusive updates on
cerebral games that will make you take
your time before making that crucial
decision that maybe the difference
between life and depth in games
that have that strategy and simulation
flavor
[Music]
thank you
welcome to crashlands
[Applause]
explore a world filled with wonder
mystery and some of these things and
then the slap them
let's slap those too just slap it all
except these
The Great Outdoors isn't so great when
you've got no indoors
best to make a home for yourself but not
just yourself
because loneliness sucks so build a
friendship because that kind of ship
won't crash after all you're gonna make
it on this planet
you need all the help you can get
[Music]
thank you
time for a change
[Music]
you wanna fight rainbows can't catch me
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Odyssey and let's take a tour of the SDF
Catalina because that's you your
princess euphora leader of the palladian
people and captain of this fine Starship
from the bridge we'll be able to upgrade
and numerous things activate our Hollow
table chart out course jump to other
systems and of course interact with our
division officers at their command
centers but let's go down a deck just
like that because in Jump light Odyssey
you'll be able to navigate all of the
decks of your Starship using our unique
never-before-seen incredible
cross-sections inspired form of
navigation and this deck is the
Promenade just below the bridge this is
where Crews spend most of their social
time and rest and recuperation coming
together for activities strengthening
relationships and even doing a little
spot of gardening or rummaging the
vending machines
now let's go to the quarter deck the
quarter deck is where the action happens
so to speak whether that be
manufacturing Building Supplies keeping
the power running showering your crew
feeding them this is the domain of your
engineering and Supply divisions and
it's what keeps the ship running day to
day
[Music]
now also a Starship needs a flight deck
this flight deck is where you'll
scramble your Fighters and launch all of
your away missions away missions are a
crucial method of gaining resources from
the systems you'll be jumping to and the
last of the Catalina's main decks is the
lower deck now usually the lower deck
when you start a run is largely empty
but as captain of the Starship we've
built this out to our design for the
needs of our crew and our mission and
next up is something that we've never
shown before
this is the jumpline drive in the engine
room you'll find the capabilities to
harness Starlight raw Starlight in a
somewhat stable form called jump light
jump light is what will power your
journey throughout the stars and
hopefully to the forever star
there is so much more to show you of the
SDF Catalina but also of jump light
Odyssey our Starship Adventure Sim and
in the coming months we'll be revealing
more and more about this title so please
wishlist the game join us on Discord and
come along for the journey
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
restaurant Empire calling the shots in
the thrilling underworld Adventure your
mission surround the show with the style
and cook up daring schemes that will
have even the tapestry book working on
its source but hold on to your Fedora
stragazzi got some cards in the game
that will make you question your choices
faster than a ship pandering whenever
pineapple belongs on Pizza when those
questionable cards pop up it's like
adding an extra kick of spice to your
lasagna things are about to get a whole
lot crazier my friends to listen up my
ambitious fastest lingers the more
clinical activities I've done the harder
music gets the police will be sticking
around like a seagull aisle for a
seafood stay once step ahead of the boys
in blue my friends you'll be the Maestro
of culinary and gangster Empire
orchestrating a team upgrading the
terroria and ensuring the pasta keeps
flowing just remember not everyone can
handle to chairs
so my friends are you prepared to die
for your cause
[Laughter]
I was acting
or was I advertise your joint real in
the hungry crowd and under money you get
from your gangsters just be prepared for
the most unexpected surprises
greetings valued employee
welcome to the Ringo Corporation
it would be your job to sort samples
there is no need
I have no doubts that you will give 110
percent
Ringo appreciates an arrested mind
empowers the grind it would be your job
to sort samples it is your duty to put
your money back into the economy
it'll be your job to sort samples the
samples are important and as such you
are important to put your money back
into the economy
[Music]
the song
greetings in place I'm Vicky and I'm Sam
we are canteen the developers of
Coronation the Sorting process our
upcoming dystopian Eric game
incorporation you'll play as Max I love
technician working for a corporately
owned state
[Music]
we love games that Foster a sensitive
routine and so built our world around
the work life sleep cycle of The Daily
Grind here's a breakdown of what that
looks like
in your day job you will sort samples
the quicker you organize them the more
money you will earn but there's a catch
you manage it will change your rules and
add complexity we've tried to emulate
the satisfaction of a job well done and
the frustration of all the free tasks
you might be wondering what you'll do
with all the money that you make Domingo
desktop PC gives you access to the
shopping catalog and pay to win games
but your first priority should always be
your bills
[Music]
as you progress through each day you
will uncover the linear narrative
through Daily News surveys
and state designated chat companions
along the journey you will find a game
world that responds to you in surprising
ways
however your routine will be disrupted
when a group of rebels decide is
satisfied with
support and uncover the truth behind the
samples
the spoiler-free prologue for you to try
on Steam we can't wait for you to play
Corporation thank you for watching work
hard
thank you
[Music]
foreign
yo did you see crashlands 2
so excited such great horror and it
looks like they really elevated the look
and feel of their game from the previous
game yeah it's so colorful the
animations are better the humor comes
across super cool and as a fan of the
fighting game genre I like what yomi 2
is doing by elevating their game as well
I'm a fgc fan I know you are it's my
world for sure yomi one was really cool
and the card game is is I was gonna say
it's delicious what I'm saying if you
like the if you like those titles make
sure to wish list them on our steam
event page pre-order them wherever they
are available Xbox
PlayStation Nintendo show them some love
by downloading the demo wherever they're
available
quick reminder that after the gorilla
Collective showcase stay tuned because
we have our publisher Spotlight showcase
coming up next where we are going to be
showing you games from Tiny build hype
train digital and Freedom Games it also
includes like I said more from Nova
lands which is a really awesome uh game
I'm here for it
I'm glad that you are thank you
thank you thanks for being here for the
game I love it Okay so we've shared
games that are horrific
strategic and downright hardcore
now we're going to slow it down and get
into our more creative stylistic and
cozy bag to share some games where we
get into all the feels as well as push
the envelope on game design and artistic
expression in ways they might not expect
I don't think they're ready they are not
ready but we're gonna get in and get
cozy cozy baby
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
cozy hike you play as this adorable
Corgi on an unforgettable vacation
along the way you might stumble across
Rusty he wants to start an animal
sanctuary and needs your help
let's mark our territory so that dogs
that we've rescue can know how to find
this place
now let's set off
on your hike you can choose where to go
and what to do
maybe you'll climb the mountain maybe
you'll unlock all of the Island's
secrets
oh wait a second what's that a beach
chair oh I can't resist the urge to
relax for a little bit take in the sun
there's a lot of little cozy spots like
this hidden throughout the island
you can find them all and relax but we
need to go now
you can find ancient Corgi artifacts
like this beautiful Cape or my Corgi
claws to let you Glide or climb your way
up mountains once you're at the top look
around to find hidden secrets here's
some ancient Corgi butt power the more
you find the higher you can climb
so let's look around and see what else
we can see here
what's that over there
that looks like a lost dog we can rescue
let's go see if we can get them
so we'll just Glide our way down
now let's just climb up
oh no we don't have enough Corgi butt
power
we could find more but let's find
another way up
I've got an idea maybe we just need some
fire
so let's just go over here grab one of
these sticks we'll light it on fire and
then we'll see what we can do let's be
careful not to cause any Corgi chaos
around here though we don't want to burn
anything but let's see okay we'll just
burn this and look what falls down a
nice little mushroom we can bounce up
there and now there he is oh for him
he's lost
he just needs a little Boop and then be
fine and ready to go
now if we go back to our Animal
Sanctuary we'll find that treble made
his way here and he's enjoying living
here let's give him a different bed you
can unlock decorations by recruiting
volunteers for your sanctuary
oh man he really loves that one
this has been your early look at a
Corky's cozy hike we've only been
working on it for a few months and we
need your help to bring it to reality
check out our Kickstarter and wishlist
us on Steam thank you so much for
watching we will see you later
[Music]
thank you
Robin and jokes you've probably already
noticed it but our beautiful little Lake
town is covered in snow and to answer
the question that's on everyone's mind
yes
will have a white Christmas
underneath green branches one of the
chances it's December
the cold ones blowing through the
mistletoeing stockings are floating over
the fireplace but is the thing about
Christmas they say you don't mean
nothing unless you got somebody else to
share it with
mail carrier Weiss hope you had a good
one out there
can't complain Frank no it's just one
more day till Christmas and Meredith
coming over but I'm alone this Christmas
and I'll be okay
special holiday
[Music]
s
come on
[Music]
all right
foreign
hey I'm here to tell you about something
a little different welcome to downtown
language learning the new way to master
languages without even realizing it you
start on this big grayscale island that
looks really dull dead and lifeless but
then as you start to learn more words
color begins to sprout out from various
places villagers move back into the
island to give you more quests or just
have conversations you essentially go
around picking up items playing mini
games and learning words in order to
bring color back to the world
the cucaba
[Music]
sanuki
hamurashi
if you want to learn a new language but
are tired of boring textbooks and a
hundred day streaks then you need to
check out Noun Town language learning
the game features over a thousand of the
most common words and phrases you need
to master and you can learn all the
major languages like Japanese Korean
Spanish and more once you've learned
some new words you'll gain access to a
ton of mini games to test your learning
[Music]
Kita and when you're feeling a little
more confident There are 16 characters
each with their own personality that you
can practice you're speaking with free
of the fear of messing up or getting
embarrassed tired senuki
[Music]
more food
downtown is available to wishlist right
now on Steam and it's releasing this
summer with console versions out in late
[Music]
thank you
those games look so fun and cozy very
inspiring who wouldn't want to go
skating with your homie Ollie the frog
or thumb your way through some
ridiculous Shenanigans with super
adventure hand it looks like those
classic N64 GameCube style games word
and the update to Lake looks super
Serene and peaceful I just want to put
on my mailman or male woman male person
outfit and deliver packages so
definitely check out those games on
Steam wish list them follow the
developers and support all the work they
put their hearts into
definitely support those devs keeping
with the pace from the last segment we
are going to get into some narrative
story driven games starting with an
adventure puzzle game that is charming
as it is beautiful and get into some
cyberpunk Noir with an update from the
team developing navalis
let's go
[Music]
please
I'm bringing a basket of baked goods to
my family
he's not doing any of the things we told
her to do we couldn't have been more
clear she's supposed to be enforcing
martial law
this goes missing and all of a sudden
there's a no goblins order I forget what
I told her to do but I think it involved
somebody's pet
foreign I was smuggling illegal pixie
dust inside the dead cat
how do we get it through her thick skull
that she's supposed to be listening to
us I am listening
did you forget I was here again what of
course not who the hell is that
[Music]
okay well you got this
the day of the royal wedding approaches
But A Change Is Coming well you RSVP for
the revolution
[Music]
oh I know you couldn't resist the chance
to place an illegal Sports bet with the
old pal Fredo welcome to guardies
inforium of wonder
[Music]
I did not slay 90 ballerinas to be
denied entry by some freckle-faced babe
I don't want to be rude but you seem
well pretty baked absolutely
oh wait your name is Count Heinrich Von
pyre yes why
and that's all for us here today please
help control the pet population have
your gargoyle spayed or neutered so long
everybody
it all starts and ends with a girl too
small and inadequate for that world of
ashtar and coal where she was born
luckily even if that place turned out to
be very hostile for her
there she met Carol until
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we're the developers of deathstrip
double blood I'm Mari I'm the producer
writer I do some of the programming I'm
Jenny I do art and I'm in charge of
Animation UI everything visual
this trick double blind is a non-linear
detective game set in a 1950s traveling
circus in this game players will have to
solve the mysterious murder of the star
magician before the circus has to leave
town by the end of the day all the
evidence and witness will be gone as we
say in the game it's high cast
Cinderella story but instead of chasing
a princess we are chasing a murderer
[Music]
the idea of setting the story in a
vintage circus came to us because we
felt like it gave us a unique
um aesthetic it will help us design
memorable characters because they each
have their own role related to how they
perform in the circus and also our
characters have their own color scheme
to go with their personalities and also
their own background stories
in this game you will play as two
different characters a detective that
has been hired to investigate the murder
and a new magician who has come to
replace the amazing hats the player will
have to switch between these two
perspectives to eventually piece things
together and come to a conclusion
in this game we have a system where we
call collection system so with every
information or item you collected you
can use them either to inquire or to
contradict what I love about this
mechanic is the non-linearity of it the
story doesn't solve lock you until you
find the right problem so you are free
to spot your own contradictions and you
can pick what you want to ask to whom
and when and you will pretty much always
get a unique response so each Journey
will be very different
the story moves forward based on what we
call action points so for example
investigating inquiring or contradicting
might all cost action points so once
your AP runs out
um this term will end and you will
switch characters and the game will move
forward to the next round so you might
want to think strategically about which
questions you would want to ask and
whether the contradiction you found is
the right one
[Music]
we hope detective game lovers will enjoy
the mystery and enjoy solving the case
in your own ways we also hope you might
like meeting these characters that we've
come to care for so much if that sounds
like something you will enjoy so please
watch this this trick double blind on
Steam and go play the demo
[Music]
who am I am I am
foreign
[Music]
hi I'm Marco creative director at
ironlands today I'm taking you behind
the scenes of nivales The cyberpunk
Slice of Life sin we are developing
bonjour
[Music]
here we are in Paris at Moab lab to do
the motion capture for nivales
every morning our actors Crystal and
Florian had to be prepped with markers
that the vikon system cameras can
detected up to 2000 frames per second
characters play a vital role in the game
your staff the guests that come to your
noodle bar corporate security gangs and
all the other people that you meet in
the city they all have their life and we
want their animations to be as true to
life as possible
besides capturing the body movement we
also capture props like umbrellas trays
meals fishing rods kitchen appliances as
well as how the characters interact with
chairs tables bars and other objects in
the game world
[Applause]
[Music]
nivales is a city that stretches from
the ocean to the clouds the entire city
is flooded
crumbling from the pressure of thousands
of buildings stacked onto each other
over hundreds of years
Diwali residents call it their home
our motion capture allows us to form
more complex interactions with
characters as you make friends enemies
compete with Rivals Forge business
Partnerships or maybe even find love
nivales is a City full of life Intrigue
and mystery
thank you for joining me on this little
tour behind the scenes
you can wishlist nivales now on Steam
and the epic game store
so Justin
yeah yeah Jay I bet you didn't know what
to buy what was about to pop off next I
definitely do not what is that it's
popping off I don't know if you're ready
for it I you got me in anticipation mode
it's time for the
[Applause]
[Music]
before that is or apparati and snap a
picture of the QR code on your screen
for an OP to grab your keys it's time
for the final free key game drop yes get
your opportunity don't let your Ops get
that opportunity grab those keys and to
match that energy
we're gonna cap things off with the gc23
we're turning the dial up to 10 getting
into some action adventure titles that
will push your Bonnet all the way back
and blow your slides off your heels we
have a few big exclusives including a
new Grime reveal and a cuddly Carnage
style update from a GC Alum let's go
[Music]
foreign
all right number two
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
skate do acrobatics kill and look cute
while doing it gory cuddly Carnage is a
foul-mouthed third person hack and slash
action adventure you play as gory a cute
but deadly synthetic cat on Frank a
sentient death stealing hoverboard
Waging War against an army of mutated
toys gory cuddly Carnage is all about
speed violence and Gore you'll have a
host of combat options to decimate
enemies and the bloodiest ways
imaginable to really amp up the Carnage
skate and slice everything with Frank's
built-in razor blades that he loves to
use next is the slam wheel that will
Crunch and Bash everything that comes in
its way charge it in the air to unleash
some hell on bigger enemies or just slam
everything in your path that's totally
up to you
the next move is my personal favorite
the hoverboard is also a rocket launcher
fires smaller Rockets against smaller
enemies or just soup it up and go
absolutely nuclear obliterating
everything you locked your sight on
except for the slashing the bashing the
dashing and the shooting there will also
be an array of upgrades to cost even
more Mayhem in the full game look at him
he's so happy you just have to buy gory
new things
when you've maimed Slade and upgraded
your way through a level everything is
of course topped off with an old school
boss battle with all the worst most
mutated and disgusting toys imaginable
these sections of the game will test
your abilities against waves of enemies
that will be destroyed in Hellfire and a
flurry of blades
but beware some of these mutant toys
will not die so easily
[Music]
gory cuddly Carnage will be available
like everything so wishlisted today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
T is looking right the whole fighting
game season is gonna be right the dawn
of the monsters DLC looks super crazy it
looks that looks so dope and we've been
following corrupt for a long time shout
out to Jesse I remember showing Gory for
the first time and it was come such a
long way as a big fan of grime which has
been doing those numbers I know this
game is going to be blowing up that's
our show everybody
so many great games and Creative Vision
thanks for watching and supporting the
games devs and
the development culture in general
be sure to check out the events page on
Steam where you can learn more about all
of the up and coming games on the show
play some of the demos wish list of
games that you'd like to get notified
about when they're available definitely
show them some love through wish listing
it helps
be sure to stay tuned for the gorilla
Collective publisher spotlights coming
up next where our friends Freedom Games
hype train digital tiny build will be
showing their latest Wares and
situations awesome stuff tomorrow if
you're in La we'll have over 40 games at
wisdom at our mix in person showcase
which will feature a live stream with
our friends at viz and the
completionists more info on our website
media in the exchange.com and on social
media and next Tuesday starting at 12 30
p.m Pacific time we have another
showcase gorilla Collective presents
games for games and black voices and
gaming definitely we'll be supporting
black game developers and women in
gaming we want to give a huge shout out
to our sponsors for helping to make this
thing happen Freedom hype train digital
PlayStation raw Fury tiny build a simple
entertainment acapara Astro gaming
herocraft joystick Adventures neon
Doctrine Raven age razor steam yes bird
wired Productions and experience Studios
much love for broadcasting partners for
supporting the Showcase
they're kind of funny and we also want
to thank you for our stream couldn't do
this without you once again we want to
we have to salute the developers all of
them that have contributed their games
their resources to make this whole thing
possible and thanks to our team Abe
Travis Joel Mary nap Matt Timmy Joel big
bite you guys and gals and everyone for
tuning in you are all awesome big shout
out to you and thanks for joining us
make sure to follow the developers you
like through their socials you can find
the games on the media in the exchange
website
check us out on Twitter at gorilla
collect and everywhere else at gorilla
Collective as well and I like to say as
well
you can also check us out on YouTube and
twitch I want to thank my co-host Jay
Watts thank you where can we find out
more about the coexist movement Justin
first off this has been amazing thank
you all so much you can find out more
about coexist gaming by going to our
website coexistgaming.com we're on all
the socials Instagram Twitter Tick Tock
all the things at coexist gaming we'd
love to coexist with you we want to give
a shout out to kind of funny for hosting
us again I'm your host Justin Woodward
head of the mix media Indie exchange
black voice and gaming one of the
advisors on black game developer fund
we're out peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
once again I'm your host Justin Woodward
co-founder of the mix Fresh Off The
Gorilla Collective welcome to the mix
publisher spotlights where we partner
with some of the most amazing Indie
Publishers we have had the honor of
working with over the years and they
have teamed up with us to drop some
amazing trailers and sneak peeks of
their up-and-coming games in this GC
publisher spotlights we are showcasing
the talent and art from Freedom Games
hype train digital and of course Tiny
build for context a lot of you not only
like playing games but also like to know
how the cake is being baked and guess
what being a baker is definitely
challenging you have to Chef up the art
mix it with design sweeten it up with
music stirring some sound design for
some tasting mechanics so it comes out
of the oven fluffy fun and tasty
if you want the recipe to stick you need
a few chefs that will Market your game
spark up a community and put that bad
boy in the bake shop window for Creative
developers who are focused on the
Artistry and craftsmanship of making
games they need assistance to help get
their art into the world that is where
Publishers come in great Publishers will
partner with developers focused on their
art and provide a positive complementary
connection where they can not only help
with the pr hookup but they could also
sous chef the production marketing and
distribution in order to make their game
successful the Publishers in the
spotlights today are Foodies for games
and game development have a knack for
understanding the developer's Vision in
order to capture an audience and give
their game the best shot of having a
successful launch and prolonged
sustainability for their studio if you
want to check out these games most of
them will be available on the gorilla
Collective event page for demos you want
to wish list them on Steam also check
out our publish your Spotlight page it's
awesome we want to thank our partners
once again as well steam IGN twitch and
Gamespot for hosting us you guys are
great we couldn't do this without you
let's get started with the spotlights
with the team who has been making moves
and hustling in the Indie space for
years with titles that range from
strategy
RPGs to Bullet hell shooters
the team has helped bring such titles as
God strike dreamscaper coramon and dark
deity to life as well as like thousands
of other Indie titles freedom is really
on a tear working with devs fresh off of
kickstarters or helping season devs
reach their next level they have some
exciting things to share with you so
let's get free with freedom games
[Music]
thank you
what's up my good people my name is
Destiny and I'm one of the marketing
managers at Freedom Games we have put
together an incredible showcase for you
guys today we have some gameplay we have
some trailers we have some interviews
and I am excited to share this with you
we also want to give a shout out to the
mix team the gorilla Collective and I
personally want to say hey to all the
fam back at Freedom Games this is going
to be incredible it's going to knock
your socks off so sit back relax and
enjoy the show
[Music]
together
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
and welcome to dwarf delve a randomly
generated roguelite set within
treacherous mines filled with Darkness
dangers and above all else loot
as a newly recruited dwarf in training
your essential duties will see you
scouring the deepest darkest Minds for
anything of value tin gold maybe even
Treasures of a less common nature
stepping into the boots of a new
doveling can be tricky luckily each time
you risk your beard for Lou to make it
out alive you can spend your ill-gotten
gains on Plenty of new tools and
equipment upgrades
assuming you make it back alive you can
use on your resources to upgrade every
element of your gear or even construct
entirely new support items you can also
exchange loot for skill points
increasing how hard you can hit how far
you can throw and how much you can carry
between your adventures you'll be able
to relax in your quarters upgrade your
living quarters with a huge array of
wallpapers rugs carpets paintings even
new cushions
here you can refine oars into crafting
materials purchase new Furnishings for
your home and even do a spot of cooking
you might even find special edible
ingredients giving you special perks
when you cook them into fully prepared
meals in the future unlock the workbench
to unpack and build flat-packed newly
purchased item blueprints even following
the included construction guide
build a rail and Minecart Network to
move your loot around whilst you dig
deeper for rarer Treasures but remember
it's best not to get too greedy these
mines are ancient and unstable one wrong
boot could cost you your life dwarf
delve was developed with a love of
exploration and discovering shiny loot
in mind from sandbox titles such as
Minecraft and stardew Valley to Rogues
such as Diablo and Borderlands I wanted
to include as many Secrets as possible
within the environment from puzzle
dungeons to obscure items that would
make players come together to solve and
build a sense of community the
experience is constantly evolving and I
look forward to raising up our battle
mallets together very soon
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
moving from our very first game to a
sequel is such a different process we
know we have to attack it with a
completely new mindset knowing what went
wrong what went right it allows us to
approach the gameplay design in
completely new ways having 54 player
classes that really change your units
and we wanted to go even further with
the classes this time we're adding
terrain effects there's a roguelike mode
a ton of enemy classes and completely
change progression systems from the
first game but the core of dark dd2 will
still be recognizable you take a cast of
characters that you can really connect
with who aren't necessarily the
strongest to start out and you fight
with them you customize them you make
them your own until they're incredibly
powerful and you've gone suddenly from
finding a couple Bandits to calling down
meteors
hello
welcome to my world Zant RAR I created
these people and peaceful lands for them
to inhabit ah actually some lands are
more peaceful than others there are
magical scenes with surprises around
every corner towns and cities for
different cultures decent citizens
and other folks here honest and
hard-working people always get what they
deserve peace is what we all want it's
on everybody's mind and soul so gaze
upon my Islands a maze at the scope of
my vision for I am RAR the god of Zant
Roar and I say
oh please help me please
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
a lot of people ask me where the concept
for Critter crops came from and like
many games I tell them that Critter crop
started as a college project then from
there after I chose to share it with the
world it became something more and I
decided that I would try my best to
incorporate my favorite pieces of video
games into a cozy experience and that
became pretty challenging when I started
bringing in the the core elements of the
game like RPG elements class choosing
combat even was a pretty bold choice to
include in a cozy game
and it's one of those things that I feel
really separates Critter crops from
other farming games and it's Unique it
has its own flavor of what cozy actually
means and it's pretty special and the
reason for it was purely because I was
trying to make the game that I want to
play the story of Critter crops is a
pretty emotional one I wanted people to
understand not only the main character
but the other characters that exist in
this world and really find someone they
can relate to and choose their favorite
people build their world the way they
would want their magical world to be so
my hope is that by the end of the game
everyone will have is harmonious amazing
place that they have built on their own
from hard work dedication
and loyalty honestly so I hope everyone
that plays Critter crops has a wonderful
time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
persevered harnessing Newfound Powers
they survive then they Thrive the
this was no longer a limit
[Music]
thank you
and that's a wrap ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for sitting with us
and watching some dope trailers
interviews and getting to know a little
bit about our developers and what it
takes to make an indie game again I want
to give a shout out to the gorilla
Collective the mix Team all of my fan at
Freedom for taking the time out to put
this together because it has been an
amazing Spotlight segment and I hope you
found something you like as a matter of
fact I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
you probably found something you love
and if you did make sure you go over to
our steam page and what is it what do we
do wishlist it wish list the games that
you like and we're coming up on the
summer I know you're going to have some
free time on your hands and we have tons
more games so check out our publisher
page go fill up your library this is me
encouraging you go do it I'll do it too
and then you know we'll just we'll play
games together anyways thanks so much
for joining us have a great summer and
happy gaming
so many dope games thanks to Freedom
games for sharing their latest and
greatest our friends and height train
digital are a team who has supported the
mix and Developers for years they were
founded in 2015 rapid 10 toes deep in
the industry with games such as breath
Edge such art Stone Shard there's no
light black book and many many more they
have some up-and-coming titles that you
definitely want to shake your Caboose to
honk your engine for and without further
Ado ladies and gentlemen check out the
latest from hype train digital
[Music]
thank you
dear adventurers welcome aboard the hype
train
as an indie game publisher we are
thrilled to invite you on a remarkable
Journey Through the rich tapestry of our
released and upcoming titles no tickets
needed just sit back and enjoy yourself
for the ride of a lifetime is about to
begin
[Music]
void train our first stop takes us deep
into The Surreal Realms of void drain a
game that has just embarked on its own
captivating journey of development after
launching void train and steam Early
Access last month the dev team has been
focusing on improving the general game
experience but expect new content such
as improved character generator and new
void creatures very soon you can learn
more about our plans in the development
roadmap envoid trains steam page
[Music]
and now we approach storm Edge an
upcoming action roguelite game that
invites you to embody the extraordinary
powers of a gifted Mage let's have a
closer look at this one
guys
[Music]
hello everyone I'm leuba a producer from
the high train digital development team
we're currently working on an exciting
project called akatori akatori is a
metroidvania slasher platformer that
will transport you to a world of
captivating pixel art and an engaging
storyline
prepare to embark on a thrilling
adventure alongside Mako a young girl
who sets out to save the world from
imminent destruction
our journey with akatori began in 2020
and ever since we launched the steam
page we've been sharing mesmerizing game
gifts on various social networks such as
Reddit and Twitter the response from The
Gaming Community has been overwhelming
with tremendous interest shown in
acaturi we've received over 100 000 wish
lists solely through our social media
efforts these numbers have instilled
confidence in US reinforcing our belief
in the potential of this project
in 2021 we participated in the Guerrilla
Collective summer of gaming showcase and
had the opportunity to present a trailer
of akatore we also conducted a closed
test of our first demo version within
the game's Discord Community the
invaluable feedback we received from the
community helped us reshape the
direction of akatori's development since
then we've expanded our development team
switched game engines and overhauled
gameplay mechanics and visuals we're now
hard at work creating a brand new demo
version which will be ready very soon
alongside the demo we plan to launch a
Kickstarter campaign to further grow and
engage the akatoi community and that's
not all in the upcoming months we'll be
unveiling additional exciting features
introducing you to intriguing characters
and showcasing the vast world of akatori
we're eager to bring this unique
metroidvania slasher platformer to life
and we're thrilled to have you join us
on this incredible journey stay tuned
for more updates and together let's make
akatori a remarkable gaming experience
thank you for your support room
Colosseum is a gladiator battle
simulator it combines elements from deck
building fighting and road-like games
experiment with equipment and weapons
combine new rules and skills to become
stronger and challenge the champions
[Music]
foreign
Coliseum today
we hope your spirits remain high for we
have now arrived at outbreak Island we
must urge you to stay vigilant this
place may have a certain charm but it is
far from the friendliest destination
hello today we will slightly the veil of
mystery over outbreak Island
in the Morning Light everything looks
quite cute and friendly but that's just
for now
every day we do something on our farm
and although you will be able to conquer
new buildings for development later this
house with a cozy garden and workshop
will remain in your heart for a long
time
here the player can experience all the
Delights of farm life growing vegetables
taking care of the territory repairing
greenhouses and strengthening fences
[Music]
the workshop in the backyard will help
with this but everything needs resources
which means it's time to head to the
sawmill
the game offers the ability to drive a
car and transport goods and building
materials at Sawmill the hero Cuts logs
into planks and assembles everything
needed in the workshop
but electricity on the island is only
available at night so our hero 6
alternative ways to solve the problem
sometimes the most interesting things
are just around the corner
the locations of outbreak Island hold
secrets and valuable loot
[Applause]
but if you don't want to face monsters
today it's time to hurry back to the
farm
outbreak island is a unique game that
allows players to immerse themselves in
the atmosphere of survival and
self-development
here you will find interesting tasks
diverse locations and a unique
atmosphere
join us and try to pass all the
challenges on your way to survival on
outbreak Island
[Applause]
hello Gatekeepers I'm George from
Gravity Lagoon studio and I'm here to
unveil our game GateKeeper
in gatekeeper you'll Venture into an
unknown Galaxy to reclaim the stolen
heart of the universe your mission is to
restore balance to the cosmos but it
won't be easy the heart is trapped
within a complex Quantum cage guarded by
Ancient Giants called the sirens prepare
for thrilling Adventures as you explore
the Galaxy battle formidable foes and
sees back the heart of the universe
earlier this year we released a
gatekeeper Eclipse a demo that received
massive support from over 100 000
players your feedback was invaluable
allowing us to refine the gameplay and
mechanics of GateKeeper
in Eclipse you had two game modes
nowhere and Aurora in nowhere you had to
fight off waves of enemies aiming to
destroy planetary Gates and steal the
heart of time and in Aurora your goal
was to protect obelisks and open portals
leading to challenging boss battles you
could choose between two unique
characters hybrid and nidum hybrid
specializes in ranged attacks utilizing
four active abilities like external bios
which bounces off enemies up to 20 times
nidum a melee hero wields fiery vortexes
with skills like circular dealing
devastating damage to anyone it touches
now we're thrilled to announce
gatekeeper Infinity our upcoming second
demo by popular demand we've added
online co-op letting you team up with
friends as fellow Gatekeepers face
tougher enemies experience enhanced
abilities and enjoy a rebalanced
gameplay unlock character progression
discover new locations embrace yourself
for an even grander Adventure we're also
introducing two additional characters in
Infinity Pandora who can be described as
a nuke Mage and Bastion a melee tank
they joined the ranks offering fresh
gameplay Styles and expanding your
strategic options we gravity Lagoon
Studio are committed to surpassing your
expectations thank you for your
unwavering support as we embark on this
extraordinary journey together stay
tuned for gatekeeper Infinity where the
fate of the universe lies in your hands
[Music]
foreign
hello we are Magnum scripto recently we
showcased a new free prologue to our
game
quasimore
quasimore is a mix of classic turn-based
roguelike RPG
Direction twist
if you survive you get to keep
everything
if you die you lose everything you took
on the mission
you play as the boss of a galactic PMC
you will explore abandoned Laboratories
space prisons and derelict temples to
complete missions for space corporations
[Music]
perfect
clone the best employees and send them
to certain death to probe the weaknesses
of your opponents die and try again
gather a team of professionals keep
track of your ammo and monitor your
equipment to be prepared for any
challenges in this space Slaughter it
will be up to you to uncover the truth
and the unforgivable acts Humanity has
committed in the deep dark depths of
space
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Journey concludes here but don't you
worry it will continue as our games come
out we sincerely hope that you have
enjoyed every moment as much as we have
don't forget to add the titles we have
showcased today to your wish list and
follow us on social media to stay up to
date with all our latest developments as
we disembark from the hype train we wish
you a safe and enjoyable Journey on your
own may it be filled with excitement
wonder and all the fun that gaming has
to offer
foreign
has some Hasty compelling games coming
out go to our steam event page watch the
Demos in the Stream
and definitely wish list their games
right now we have one of the most iconic
Publishers in the scene starting out as
Indies themselves with their own title
no time to explain and blowing up with
plunge Club speedrunners hello neighbor
party hard and a ton of other titles
they're now working with developers on
starting new independent franchises that
launch from a creative Place once again
pull out that signature orange out of
the closet and check out the tiny build
showcase
[Music]
no
hello everybody and welcome once again
to the tiny gold showcase at the mix
event we have got heaps of fun
announcements today from game reveals to
free demos and some interesting news
about Indie Gaming's most prolific
homeowner
[Music]
San Rafaela Paradise full of new
opportunities
[Music]
the destiny of San Rafaela lies in your
hands
wish list now on Steel
hey punks I'm Chuck and I'm gonna teach
you how to survive in the future
goodness Corporation runs the show
around here so if you want to escape the
undercity you best get some good person
points only losers train old school
style sit on your butt get buffed with
neurotraining train smart and install
software in your government mandated
brain implant what could go wrong people
ate slime now gives you energy and makes
you less hungry you do not want to be
hungry in the future
it's about all that I can be bothered to
tell you about today so go kick some
button don't forget to play the steam
punch Club 2 Fast Forward
foreign
[Music]
made a pizza
should never
ever
[Music]
do a cyber manicure I wrote this song
about myself
[Music]
try the free demo and wishlist on Steam
now
[Music]
the part that nobody said wasn't allowed
to happen so without further Ado it is
our absolute pleasure to introduce you
to slime Pre-K
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
pilot mode activated welcome to Black
Skylands
explore the skies in this open world
Base building Adventure jump into an
airshow gather resources build weapons
and fight an Ever looming Threat all
while uncovering the many Secrets hidden
in the clouds over three centuries ago a
meteorite fell to Earth forever Changing
Life on the planet players will step
into the shoes of Eva a talented Airship
pilot
Eva is tasked with visiting the small
colony of asput where Pirates and
monsters alike have been ruthlessly
attacked
seeing the sheer Havoc these enemies
have wrought Eva decides that she is
going to need some big ships with big
weapons in order to save the colony
that's where you come in explore an
expansive world complete with many
unique floating islands travel through
forests Farms snow lands and ruins with
your trusty moth Luma to help you with
moving things to your ship pick up side
quests uncover Secrets gather treasure
solve puzzles and meet interesting
characters
but keep your wits about you because you
never know what dangers lurk in the dark
skies
prepared to fight on both land and in
disguise combine aerial and ground
fighting tactics you grappling hook to
close in quickly on enemies and take
them by surprise
powerful weapons that you can change on
the fly to adapt to the battle at hand
aboard the fathership Eva is able to
upgrade herself and her equipment
with a variety of weapons at her
disposal from crossbows to rocket
launchers and nearly 30 modification
options each
players are able to truly craft the
perfect Arsenal to cater to their own
personal play style
not every ship is perfect and Eva's
airships are no exception you'll find
throughout the game that you can upgrade
your ships and choose what types of guns
to use
you'll need to use the resources you've
gathered on your Journeys to keep your
ships in Tip-Top shape
[Music]
along with the main story of black
skylines you'll meet others in the world
that need your help complete these
quests to gain experience and of course
valuable resources you can also take on
difficult challenge quests to find more
Bountiful rewards black Skylands is full
of intriguing twists exciting combat and
loads of great customization for both
your characters and your ships you never
know what you might discover while
exploring the sky
but one thing is for certain
your efforts may just mean the
difference between the end of Earth's
existence or the beginning of its new
one
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're really excited to tell you all
about our plans for the future of spider
heck today where we're going to be
looking back at the updates we've
released over the past year and sharing
our exciting plans for the upcoming
summer update and Beyond so before we
swing into the Future Let's Take a look
back at where we've been
since the release of spider heck we've
been hard at work building out new game
modes features and content like parkour
mode where you run jump and Dodge your
way through obstacles against the clock
and who can forget the rush of wielding
new weapons
we've added gravity grenades the gravity
saw and the auto shotgun for more
carnage oh and let's not Overlook the
portals that help you escape and murder
you in equal amounts
and of course the infamous pain levels
that tested your limits and Sanity it's
been quite a journey so far hasn't it
but we're far from done on spider heck
so let's dive into what lies ahead for
our upcoming summer update
brace yourselves because there's a lot
and at the end we have something extra
special to announce so don't go anywhere
first up we're introducing the versus
map editor that's right folks we're
putting the power of Creation in your
hands allowing you to create unique
Battlegrounds for your Fierce battles
with a plethora of tools and options at
your disposal you can shape the Arenas
to match your wildest imagination and we
can't wait to see what you come up with
in June when this feature releases
next up
chained Invincible enemies
lasers swinging on hinges platforms
hanging by a thread
yep we're cranking up the insanity with
new level hazards your spider senses
will be tingling as you navigate these
treacherous environments testing your
reflexes and wits
it's a wild ride you won't want to miss
and don't worry most of these new
hazards will be available in both the
parkour and versus map editors in our
anniversary update later this year
but wait there's more we're shaking
things up with the introduction of
limited tears of heck the name might
change before it gets to you
and this is planned for release later
this summer
these limited time tiers will offer you
a chance to unlock cosmetics and rewards
as you conquer the challenges they throw
your way and here's the kicker we're
even going to let you submit your own
devilish tears upon an unsuspecting
public
we're still not done the scroll of heck
is an in-game list that will unveil all
of the cosmetics and their unlocked
conditions working out how to unlock the
game's various Cosmetics was an annoying
process and we've added the scroll to
make it easier to know what you need to
do
as an added bonus you'll progress
through the game will be tracked and as
you complete more of the scroll you'll
be rewarded with additional Cosmetics to
flaunt your spider Style
and we're still not done for all you
Achievement Hunters out there we've got
you covered we're unleashing 10 brand
new achievements including Conquering
the grueling pain levels and showcasing
your parkour prowess
it's time to prove your spider skills
and earn those bragging rights
alright hold on to your webs because
we're not done yet and you patiently
waited now it's time for the big news we
promise
in fact we lied
it's two big pieces of news
dedicated servers are coming to spider
heck
picture this online gameplay which is
reliable stable and where the host has
no advantage
say goodbye to those pesky connection
issues and hello to smooth the gameplay
with dedicated servers you can focus on
perfecting your swing and outmaneuvering
your opponents without worrying about
pesky hiccups
that's not all we're also introducing
cross play
you'll be able to team up with friends
and foes alike no matter if they play on
PC console or even a web-enabled toaster
hey we don't judge
it's all about connecting players
regardless of platform choice and
letting everyone murder each other's
spiders freely
and so that brings us to the end of this
update the summer update is just around
the corner and we'll be continuing to
add more and more to spider heck as time
goes by
keep an eye on our socials and join us
in the Discord to make sure you never
miss any news as soon as it's available
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go everybody there you have it
that's the show thank you so much for
joining those you sincerely hope that
you've enjoyed it please don't forget to
follow us on social media at tidal
Orange it's up to date with all the
latest news and announcements and until
next time
take care bye bye
[Music]
I love checking out what is coming up
next from Tiny build you never know what
to expect so colorful so good well that
wraps up our publisher Spotlight
showcase we want to say thanks to all of
the Publishers for participating in this
show hype train digital Freedom Games
and Tiny build of course for sharing
their latest and greatest and all the
devs who have entrusted their life and
babies to these Partners you guys better
keep these devs safe and do right by
them or we're coming after you we want
to give a shout out to all of our
broadcasting partners for supporting the
Showcase and the developers on the
stream twitch IGN Gamespot and steam you
guys are super dope games from this
showcase will be also be a part of the
gorilla Collective steam event page so
make sure to check that out and wish
list the games we want to say thank you
to the mix team for putting this
together Timmy Joel Travis Matt a fully
illustrator it and myself of course if
you are in La make sure to come through
to our mix live event at wisdom it's a
dope Art Space where we're gonna
showcase over 40 games we'll have some
food and some drinks and we're gonna
also have a stream hosted by the
completionist himself and Bannon from
viz Indie showcase next week we're also
going to have an additional updated GC
showcase as well as black voices and
gaming and games for games streams that
will celebrate Black voice and gaming
and women in gaming because it's
definitely needed
once again I am your host Justin
Woodward co-founder of the mix and tear
bang entertainment BV uh all that stuff
we will see you again soon
peace
[Music]